字幕: YAYOI YOKOYAMA
校正: Kazunori Akashi
初めまして　私は 新田のんのと申します
「のんの」はアイヌ語で
花という意味があるんですけれども
良く 素敵だね かわいらしい名前だね
という風に言っていただけます
しかし私のお母さんには アスファルトを
突き破って生えてくるお花のように
逞しく強く生きるのよという風に
言われながら育ってきました
今日は 意識のバリアを取り払うコツ
ということで一つ提案していきたいと思います
皆さんは 私を見てまず
どんな印象を受けましたか？
まず 車いすに乗っているな
という風に気づきましたよね
そのほかには どんな印象を受けたでしょうか
例えば 見た目で 怖そう 優しそう
体の 強そう 弱そうという風に
それぞれ見た目で第一印象を決めると
思うんですけれども
実際にお話しをしてみると
全然違う印象だったなという風な経験が
皆さんもあると思います
私は 小学校の時にスキー学習と
いうものに参加したんですけれども
スノーボードに座る部分の椅子を取り付けた
なんちゃってスキーというものに乗って
スキー遠足にみんなと一緒に参加しました
私は小学校の３年生から
車いすマラソンに参加しているんですけれども
今乗っているこの車いすと同じもので
ショートレースの３キロに初めて参加しました
その時に 実は金色の車いすに乗った
おばあちゃんがいたんです
私は当時 おばあちゃんにまさか
負けるわけはないだろうという風に思いながら
スタートしたんですが
残念ながら負けてしまいました
私はとっても悔しかったです
でもその悔しさをバネに
たくさんたくさん練習を積み重ねた結果
翌年に そのおばあちゃんを追い越して
なんと優勝することができました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
ショートレースで３キロから始めた私が
５キロへと進み
そのあとに中学校からですね
本格的に競技用の車いすの
レーサーというものにも乗りました
実際に見てもらうと分かると
思うんですけれども
前のめりになって前傾をして車いすを漕いで
マラソンというものを続けています
さて そんな私なんですけれども
実は 根っからのスポーツウーマンですね
ただ車いすに乗っている姿を見ただけだと
想像しにくいのではないでしょうか
そんな私に 実は転機が訪れたのが
2015年の12月になります
皆さんはノルディックスキーという競技を
ご存じでしょうか
メディアに取り上げられていることも多いので
知っているという方もいらっしゃると思います
私はその12月に初めて旭岳という場所で
強化合宿に参加させていただきました
それをきっかけに
ノルディックスキーを始めたのですが
もうその ノルディックスキーという競技の
虜になってしまいました
普段は雪がバリアに感じているんですけれども
やっぱり車いすではなく
シットスキーというものに乗った瞬間に
自由に動くことが出来たんです
とても楽しかったです
そんなシットスキーは アルペンスキーの
スキー板があると思うんですけれども
それよりも細いものを使っています
これは 私が描いている絵なので
ちょっと見にくいかもしれないんですけれども
そのスキー板の上に
座るための椅子を取り付けた
シットスキーというもので競技をしています
私の様に 車いすに乗っている選手も
いるんですけれども
そのクラス分けは
座位というクラスになります
その他にも 足を切断した選手も
同じように座位というクラスにいます
そんな中ですね 本当にたくさんの
今までお世話になった方々のおかげで
2018年の平昌パラリンピックに
出場することができました
（拍手）
私は山をですね 冬の雪山を登って下る—
かなり高低差があるんですけれども
そのノルディックスキーという競技で21位
またそのノルディックスキーに
射撃の要素を加えた—
エアライフルで遠くの的を撃つんですけれども
その競技では13位という結果でした
これは宮の沢の射撃場で練習をしている
様子になるんですけれども
この様に銃を構えてですね
まず その場所に行ったら横に倒れるんですね
で 倒れた後に射撃で撃って
また起き上がってということをして
また 滑っています
そんな私がですね
ちょっと昔話をしたいと思うのですが
私が中学校の頃
社会のグループ学習の時に
一人の女の子に言われたことがあります
私 あなたが車いすだから嫌いって
言われたんですね
とってもびっくりしました
ですが 陰口をコソコソ言われるよりも
直接言ってもらえて良かったな
という風に思っています
私がその子になんで嫌いなのという風に聞くと
「わからない」と答えました
あなたに対して普通に接したらいいのか
それとも 何か手伝った方がいいのか
それがわからないという風に言われたんですね
その様に 私とその子の間には
少し壁があったようです
その他にも 例えばなんですけれども
皆さんが電車に普段乗っているときに
人の顔色をうかがって 席を譲ろうかどうか
悩んだりする方もいるのではないでしょうか
これも一種の 意識のバリアと言えると思います
例えば皆さんが バスに乗るということを
まず 何もやり方を知らないとします
そんな時に 周りの人の行動を見て
ようやく切符を入れるんだなっていう風に
わかって行動すると思うんですけれども
これって 時間のロスになりますよね
実際に すぐに教えてくださいと
周りの人に聞けば分かると思います
ですが それがなかなか難しいですね
やって欲しいこと 助けて下さいということと
実際はやって欲しくないっていうこと
その２点を きちんと相手に伝えられるような
そんな風に気軽に話し合えるような
社会になっていくと素晴らしいな
という風に思いました
そんな中で 絶対にやられたら
困ることっていうのがあります
やって欲しくないことには
実は種類があると気づきました
そんな やって欲しくないこと
絶対に困ることというのは
具体的に言うと
急に後ろから車いすを押されることです
これをされると 実はこの車いすのタイヤと
泥除けカバーがついているんですけれども
そこの間に 指を こう
ガッと挟んでしまうんですね
なので かなりそれが痛いんです
皮ベリッて剥がれちゃうんですよ
なので それを無くすために
一言ですね
手伝いましょうかという風に
言っていただけると とても安心します
その他に 自分でやるべき事
これは やるべき事だから
やられたら嫌な事というものがあります
具体的にお話をすると
私は家が 山の坂道の中に
あるんですけれども
だいたい人通りがないんですね
そして私は美術を習っている
学生なんですけれども
絵画で絵を描く時の大きなキャンバスを
この背中に挟めて歩くことが多いです
だいたい大きさが 本当に私の座高より大きい
こんなに大きいものになるんですけれども
それをたまたま通った人が見ると
すごく大変そうだなという風に
見えるんだと思います
大丈夫ですか お手伝いしましょうかと
言っていただけるのは
本当にありがたいんですけれども
当然 毎回人が通るわけじゃないので
自分で行かなければなりません
そんな時に 大丈夫ですとただ言うと
「あー せっかく声を掛けたのに」
「こいつちょっと生意気だな」って思われたら
すごく嫌だなって思うんです
なのでひと言 ありがとうございますと
きちんと相手に感謝の気持ちを
伝えるようにしています
意識のバリアを取り払い
自分の意見をきちんと言える
そういったことが
とても大切なことだと思います
お互いの勘違いを無くすためにも きちんと
断るときには ありがとうという風に
伝えることが大切だと思います
そんな断ることに対しても寛容的な社会に
なっていけると素晴らしいと思うので
周りの人も もちろん私自身も
もっともっと行動を起こして
変えていきたいと考えています
私は 学校の美術の教員になるのが
夢なんですけれども
意識のバリアを取り払って
また自分の意見をきちんと相手に伝えられ
周りの環境をじーっと目を配っていけるような
そんな人たちを育てていきたいな
という風に考えています
単純なことかもしれませんが
ありがとうと相手に伝えるということと
また 大丈夫かな 声を掛けて
みようかなという風に
積極的に声がけをしていくと
もっともっと良い世界に
なっていくのではないかと思いました
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）